boa tarde
muito boa tarde é antes de começarem
estudo estava diz já não só votar pra
vocês mas a todas as pessoas que estão
lá em casa a ver conosco ela streaming
que irão ficar sentados com voz co
o primeiro vai fazer isso quartel em vez
de estarem aqui conosco é a participar
neste momento e eu vou te contar uma
coisa ao longo da tarde
eu fui vendo todas as conferências foram
feitas e admite que é fácil subir - eles
tinham um carro nervoso qualquer que
fosse acontecer em cima do palco e na
última meia hora do coffee break ou lá
como quiserem chamar
não é virar profissão não a fazer o que
quer que seja mas sem encantar o acordo
a mata porque foi uma coisa que toca o
pingo para algumas pessoas aqui dentro e
influenciou bastante a minha vida e eu
queria vir e todas as pessoas que quando
eu disser saco na mata vocês disse assim
como para melhorar aqui espírito esta
sala akunamatata ok ok a kuna mata
ok akunamatata a é tão fácil viver foi
continuando
vamos lá quem sabe se agora a sério que
é que o clipe vestir um casuísmo unidade
nesta nesta minha apresentação que aliás
eu eu tenho 17 anos e 15 mil da lei com
12 anos já trata por senhor
portanto vamos vamos tratar isto é bom
ok ok kim ok ok eu devo admitir aí é
verdade eu errei mas parem eu sou
ingênua que seria como uma criança e eu
diria esse tipo de sons na frente já que
tanto ama
vamos começar a falar a sério embora lá
solar e deixou convencer o que vocês
olhem para esta frase esta fase não vai
dar um tempo aqui porque as coisas têm
que rolar mas eu quero que você escolhe
mais ou menos a mensagem desta frase que
esquecer tudo o que aconteceu e vai ser
feliz vai eu quero que vocês lembram
muito bem esta frase todas as pessoas
que aqui estão e bora lá passar a outra
coisa que é uma história que acho que é
parte daquilo que eu sou hoje aquilo que
me faz estar aqui hoje foi muitas
situações que aconteceram na minha vida
cuidar de outra maneira de dizer à minha
maneira de ver as coisas que é história
e tornou se pública a uns tempos pra mim
há muito tempo há oito meses porque só
tem 17 anos mas eu fui eu fui da nato
meu pai quando tinha menos de um ano de
idade e ea verdade é que o fax da nato o
meu pai eu podia ver isso como uma forma
de volta para ver isso como uma forma da
morte não quer ver a minha frente mas é
eu devo que o sinceramente agora não em
ironizando porque acho que muda muito a
forma eu agradeço muito por que por que
algumas pessoas se esquecem o trajeto
sabem que eu fiz uma música de cada
linha avon que a mulher da minha vida ea
minha mãe é que eu deixe um grande
obrigado que não puderam estar aqui hoje
mas
obrigado mas amo que simplesmente
tiveram toda a educação todas essas duas
mulheres da formação toda forma de ver a
vida da forma de encarar aquilo que o
que cheire que o faz estar aqui e falar
sobre o sob a perspectiva que eu estou a
defender que apenas rir porque sim e às
vezes porque não na melhores coisas para
fazer mas é que o faz tarde de hoje eu
agradeço celas e todas as mulheres que
criaram não foi preciso um homem pra
fazer a iupar em que o começo agora
falando a sério eu discordo totalmente
da outra frase que ele está não sei qual
é a vossa opinião mas eu discordo eu
acho que não se deve esquecer
não se esqueça das coisas que nos
acontecem
não se esqueça as coisas mas não
esquecem as coisas boas
tem-se medo é normal mas acredita em uma
coisa é preciso escuridão por uma
estrela brilhar no céu e às vezes as
pessoas que assistiu a toda a gente que
está eu tento viver da música e o pavão
mandando uns bitaites sobre o que acha
sobre o que eu penso
mas amo todos nós aqui estamos numa
música particular que estamos num disco
e particulares temos um artista nos faz
cantar a música vevo o som deu aquela
guitarrinha toda a gente gosta dos
brasileiros mas é verdade que sem
silêncio ouvir música
o silêncio é parte mais importante da
música é oprimido spears tua caos com
pães todos os sorvetes surgimentos maus
que estão na tua vida fazem dar valor
aos bons errada que eu sou muito sincero
com vocês
eu nunca me queixei por ter um bolo de
aniversário mais do que os outros que os
outros players mas porque eu sabia que
essas pessoas que estavam fazendo tudo
para vir comigo não achavam que apenas
um golo iria satisfazer mãe é verdade
isso tudo muda é a perspectiva com que
talvez as coisas
essa é a realidade é só esta abrigados
têxteis curar sua volta e isso nunca se
pode esquecer nunca esqueça das coisas
que acontecem mal nunca aconteça sobre
as coisas que acontecem bom e o que sim
vou fazer vou que graça de deus ainda
com 17 anos já tinha gravado um disco é
verdade eu realizei o sonho da minha
vida um puto com suco buscador e um
microfone
hoje realizou e terceiro é eu a gente
chora quando penso nisto porque tudo
aquilo que aconteceu na vida dá um tiro
naquele jogo eu vou olhar agora preocupa
vocês olharem com atenção para que logo
é que o lance maior o tempo esse mal do
computador toda a gente escreve no
facebook
isso muda tudo que é o de ou muda tudo o
que é o dia antes de tudo o que é o de
80 tudo o que eu de 81 de tudo porque
porque é verdade já aconteceram coisas
mais clean também com vocês todos temos
os nossos problemas na vida mas fui-me
capacidade por ali dois pontos como
doutor um significado para mim daquela
pessoa
às vezes as coisas pequenas como dois
pontos fazem mudar todo o significado
entre os conselhos que eu vejo aquilo e
recordam que o que eu sou nada muda além
disso ea verdade é que eu comprovo isso
por culto catar varrido clinton com um
problama cristian ea verdade é que se
tornou isto aqui vamos manter essa
imagem que durante o tempo que uma
imagem que como devem calcular e no
orgulho porque estou fazendo uma careta
horrível e minha avó também notar as
mesmas figuras mas continuando
isto foi esta a expressão insisto
naquilo que eu sou e acredita esse dia
tem se um dia muito triste porque era o
dia em que eu me mudar para lisboa e que
iria afastar de todas as pessoas de quem
sempre me deram apoio foram aquelas duas
pessoas e queria passar a seguir o meu
próprio rumo e esta foi a forma nós
arranjamos nos induz discutirmos no
entanto os mais crentes mas olhem para o
riso é importante
às vezes as pessoas perguntam por que eu
faço caretas nas fotos é por causa desta
pessoa em causa da forma como encara a
vida deve ser igual à de escravo
continuando eu as experiências que vivi
na minha vida e eu não vou falar do
hockey acho que estraguei isto a jovem
não vou falar do típico português vou
falar do típico humano o ser humano tem
muita mania de usar esta frase reclama
da vida ser uma reclamar o ser humano
diz malu em estudo é tão quer usar
realmente a frase lama da vida usado da
forma certa
por reclamar da vida não é nada mais que
uma questão de perspectivas do que marca
a vida do que ver a vida de outra forma
de ver a vida do outro prisma estados
porque tu lhe deste lado
o k2 tipos pessoas no mundo as pessoas
escolham ou nada e vem na van
isso só escolham na lei dizem que podem
fazer um tudo
a estes dois tipos de pessoas no mundo
alta pessoas que reclamam e as pessoas
que amam a verdade é essa
twitter claro todos nós devemos sons
todos não tínhamos um dia em ser
astronauta turistas ator/atriz 14 retas
leva da música os moradores
mas de uma coisa eu vou usar
imaginem que eu queria ser agricultor
existe uma planta que eu sinceramente
não sei o nome mas quando nós plantamos
mora cinco anos aquele cheiro do tipo
favor dando obrigado grande festa da
senhora faz show mora há cinco anos e
que cheira e agora vamos lá eu vou estar
com vocês são pessoas inteligentes e eu
vou falar isso na perspectiva do
agricultor foi outro agricultor dizer
que as garças 5 anos uma coisa que não
parece veículo esmal
não tem sentido sua própria figura as
dúvidas existem mas a verdade é que nos
faz cinco anos a planta cresço em apenas
duas semanas
a verdade é que as outras pessoas que
andavam comentar
tu és burro não fazia sentido e taeq
próprio seu a planta que o bambu e que
eu tenho o maior orgulho
só peço que façam essa analogia se o teu
próprio agricultor cultiva o teu sonho
sinai o teu sonho porque acredita as
suas boas e más no mundo
as pessoas que vão enviar as sugestões
jari hábitos simples botão start e tem
suas razões mas também vai ver aquelas
que a montadora e trânsito tem sucesso
mas acredita é a única pessoa que vai
estar contigo nos momentos altos e
baixos da tua vida
vai ser tudo é grave tu és o único faz
encarar as derrotas
vai sobrar as vitórias mas estava sempre
até o fim dos seus dias desde o primeiro
até o último suspiro isto quartzo
continuando tudo isso fez com que eu
crianças da frase of esta frase que iria
mandar fora para tudo o que rir queria
lutar e vencer
irei cantar e cultivar a crescer tur e
só tu os teus sonhos e pedir desculpa eu
só tem mais uma coisa histórica silva
docentes e os fatos mas acho que é
importante ser dito que tudo na vida
pode ser metaforiza duprat rio não só é
o melhor remédio como também a melhor
doença
não esqueça de uma coisa ir porque se é
mais autêntico forma da sociedade
a verdade é esta eu quando era mais o
vínculo tinha 11 anos
eu tenho um amigo que estava passando
por uma dificuldade na vida e como todos
passamos e eu gosto de escrever escrever
uma letra com ela em uma quadra que
ainda hoje não motiva a seguir os meus
sonhos até traçar o meu trilho a ser o
próprio eo criativos o favor que eu não
tenho microfones plantou usar o
telemóvel sempre que eu apontar o
telemóvel pra vocês vocês vão dizer um
sorriso
após contar com vocês cai cai é desculpa
e os financistas eu não sou cantora
wilma queimarem cantor - o cantor
eu faço letras mas é muito simples
quem quiser acompanhar por saber o ritmo
eu e tu nós dois em tudo na vida
procuramos um sorriso e eu e tu nós dois
há em tudo na vida encontramos um ciss e
o ou ou o e wow wow
a primeira isso obrigar para lá que toda
forma como vocês querem pode ser tão
quem souber quem quiser acompanhar tal
livro eu e tu nós dois em tudo na vida
procuramos os ris iea
eu e tu nós dois em tudo na vida
encontramos uns riffs o eu ou o eu ou o
ou o muito obrigado e eu fui pra ele não
está com vocês